Oh, my! How lovely!
This certainly is a splendid academy.
I'm so glad that I transferred here.
What is this?
Jabami.
Yes, what is it?
Listen, you know how to gamble?
Gamble, did you say?
Well, poker and mah-jongg, and such...
I am familiar with the rules, at least.
I see. Right.
See, at this academy,
gambling's always been all the rage.
Once classes end, you'll see
gambling going on everywhere.
And since there are a lot
of rich students here,
the stakes are ridiculously high.
I'm sure you'll get asked sooner or later,
so better watch your--
Well, well. That's certainly something
to look forward to.
Jabami! Welcome to Year Two, Flower Class!
Which school did you transfer from?
- Any hobbies?
- What do you do on days off?
- Have a boyfriend?
- Let's be friends!
Oh, yes, I hope we can be friends, too.
Nice to meet you! I'm Mary Saotome.
I hope we can be friends!
I hope we can be friends, too, Mary.
Are you free after this, Jabami?
Would you like to gamble with me?
Hey, what?
- Mary's gonna gamble with the new girl!
- Think she's gonna pull that one?
- What kind of gambling you have in mind?
- It's called Ballot Rock-Paper-Scissors,
a gambling game that our class devised.
First, everyone in our class draws either
a rock, scissors or paper on a card.
Then they drop those cards into the box
so we can't see them.
We both draw three cards
from the box, choose just one,
and play Rock-Paper-Scissors.
If it's a stalemate, we draw from
the remaining two cards and play again.
If it's a stalemate all three times,
it's a draw. That makes up one game.
Unlike normal Rock-Paper-Scissors,
you don't always show your entire hand.
Trying to read each other under
such unfair circumstances is the appeal.
Sounds fun! I'd love to try it.
Okay! That's what I like to hear.
Jabami--
Fido, fetch the chips.
I said fetch.
Yes, ma'am.
These are the chips.